e información económica en france 24
estamos para eso con daniel hablando
periodista experta de la redacción que
nos va a contar los principales temas de
esta jornada ni la bienvenida y
empezamos hablando de la minera
brasileña vale que pagará una millonaria
compensación a los habitantes de minas
gerais en brasil
hola liliana comencemos por decir que
esta es una de las mayores exportadoras
de hierro del mundo y hace dos años
colapsó la presa de una de sus minas en
el municipio de brumadinho dejando más
de 270 muertos vale acordó pagar casi 7
mil millones de dólares en daños y
compensaciones este es el acuerdo más
grande de este tipo jamás alcanzado en
américa latina según el gobierno de
minas gerais la ruptura de la presa
desató una torrente de desechos mineros
que entraron lo equivalente de lilian
haga las cuentas 300 estadios de fútbol
quedaron bajo el lodo tóxico hoy justo
dos años después las autoridades hablan
de que 11 personas siguen desaparecidas
la compañía dijo que no sólo pagaría a
las familias afectadas sino que también
va a reparar
completo el daño medioambiental y para
tener una dimensión de lo que van a
pagar en compensaciones esta cifra es
casi la mitad de todos los ingresos
operativos que tuvo vale en 2019 daniela
y en australia hay batallas de grandes
tecnológicas cuéntanos de qué se trata
todo comenzó la semana la última semana
de enero cuando google amenazó con sacar
a su famoso motor de búsqueda de
australia si el gobierno seguía con sus
planes contra los gigantes tecnológicos
este jueves el primer ministro scott
morrison tuvo una reunión virtual con el
jefe de alphabet que es la matriz de
google y que calificó de bastante
constructiva sin embargo el proyecto de
ley sigue en pie y lo que busca es que
empresas como facebook o google paguen a
las firmas de medios de manera justa por
usar el contenido que extraen de sus
sitios web en medio de esta pelea
apareció un tercer participante la
también estadounidense microsoft que
puso su buscador bing a disposición de
australia si se cumplen las amenazas de
google que es el responsable de más del
95%
de las búsquedas de este país y si se
aprueba la ley ellos no estarían sujetos
a este coro daniela y la ocde propuso
una reforma tributaria en chile- el
también conocido como club de países
ricos dice que esta nación debe reforzar
el poder distributivo de sus impuestos
en otras palabras aumentar la base
gravable del impuesto de renta o sea el
número de personas que efectivamente
pagan y buscar una manera más equitativa
de entregárselos a los más pobres este
organismo destaca que chile es el país
con el ingreso por habitante más alto de
américa latina y el que más crece por
encima de otros grandes como eeuu y
japón pero también es uno de los más
desiguales lilia ramírez de hecho el 53
por ciento de los hogares están
clasificados como económicamente
vulnerables lo que significa que no
tienen un colchón financiero para
protegerse contra una caída repentina de
los ingresos y esa cifra es del 39 por
ciento en promedio en todo el resto de
países pues la desigualdad en chile es
bastante alta
se cree que el 1 por ciento de los más
ricos acapara una cuarta parte de toda
la riqueza de este país
daniela y alemania lanzó un nuevo
paquete de ayudas para sus ciudadanos
si tanto las familias como las empresas
de los sectores más castigados por las
prolongadas restricciones van a recibir
estas nuevas ayudas por ejemplo él iba
en bares y restaurantes bajará del 16%
hasta el 7% hasta finales de 2022
también habrá una nueva prima para los
hogares de 150 euros por cada hijo que
tengan y un pago único de un monto
similar para quienes tengan bajos
ingresos a nivel empresarial habrá un
apoyo de la cultura de mil millones de
euros y vamos ahora daniela con los
indicadores de la jornada si en eeuu los
buenos datos de empleo les dieron nuevos
récords a dos de sus principales índices
que son el standard and poor's y el
tecnológico nasdaq estas noticias
también les dieron un impulso a las
bolsas europeas lideradas de nuevo por
italia que estrena un banquero en su
gobierno un nombramiento que ha sido
bastante aplaudido al menos en el
mercado bursátil y en américa latina
hubo resultados mixtos con un buen
ascenso en la bolsa de buenos aires y la
cita al día con que lo sorprende hoy
daniela
43 % liliana subió el índice mundial de
precios de los alimentos en enero
subieron los precios por octavo mes
consecutivo y alcanzaron máximos desde
julio de 2014 los que más subieron
liliana no te lo cereales azúcar y
aceites vegetales gracia daniela por la
información de economía y ustedes
gracias por estar en tras 24 continúan
en france 24 punto com
[Música]